There are two options for transferring
stitches from the ribber to the main bed.
You can also use this the other way.
From the main bed down to the ribber
using a double eyed needle.
First take the stitch off
onto that double eyed needle.
Flip the needle and slide
the stitch to the other end.
Then position the opening of the double
eyed needle over the hook of the main
bed needle and slip off the stitch.
Now this looks harder than it is.
Once you get a feel for it and establish
a rhythm, it goes pretty quickly.
If you're like me and your double eyed
needle likes to play hide and seek,
try using two transfer tools.
From the top, slip the ribber stitch
to the transfer tool and put
the ribber needle out of work.
From the bottom, insert a second transfer
tool into the stitch and transfer
that stitch to the new tool.
Put the eye of that second tool over
the main bed needle and slip
the stitch to the main bed needle.
Again, this looks harder than it is
and you may prefer this method even if you
can find that pesky double eyed needle.